sí
hola bienvenidos al debate de france 24
soy santiago lópez gonzález 12 días han
transcurrido desde el inicio de la
invasión de rusia al territorio
ucraniano esta operación militar a gran
escala ha provocado un éxodo masivo de
ciudadanos de ese país hacia otras
naciones vecinas para evitar caer bajo
el fuego cruzado entre los ejércitos
precisamente de rusia y ucrania según el
alto comisionado de naciones unidas para
los refugiados acnur entre un millón
quinientos treinta y cuatro mil 792
refugiados y también cerca de 17
millones han abandonado el país
solamente en estos 12 días después de
iniciado este conflicto
según acnur se trata de la crisis de
refugiados son más de más rápido
crecimiento en europa desde la segunda
guerra mundial veamos algunas de las
cifras cifras precisamente de acuerdo a
acnur ya estatista polonia es el país
que más refugiados procedentes de
ucrania ha recibido en estos 12 días se
habla de una cifra oficial de 649 mil
903 aunque se habla que podría superar
el millón de personas debido a que
muchos de estos ciudadanos
están ingresando al territorio polaco
tienen doble ciudadanía y no ingresan
como ciudadanos ucranianos sino que lo
hacen con los otros pasaportes de las
otras ciudadanía que poseen le sigue
hungría con 144 mil 738 estos dos países
polonia y hungría son parte de la unión
europea en tercer lugar esta moldavia
que ha recibido 103 mil 254 eslovaquia
que también es territorio comunitario 90
mil 329 le sigue rumanía también
territorio de la web ha recibido hasta
ahora 57 mil 152 refugiados rusia que es
en este caso el país agresor
recibido 53.300 y ustedes se preguntarán
por qué la gente querría ir a rusia pues
muchas personas en ucrania tienen
familiares en rusia o tienen doble
ciudadanía heredada desde la época
soviética que se le permitía a los
ciudadanos tener tanto la ciudadanía
rusa como la de su país de origen que
fuera cualquiera de estas 15 ex
repúblicas soviéticas
le sigue de la luz que ha recibido a 374
personas otras 110 mil 876 han partido
hacia otros países de la unión europea
donde ya había establecida con
anterioridad una diáspora ucraniana
estamos hablando de países como alemania
el reino unido la república checa grecia
chipre y portugal en este último país
hay una gran comunidad de ucranianos y
moldavos pero también una cifra similar
es decir estamos hablando también de
unas 110 mil personas han ido mucho más
allá de las fronteras de la unión
europea a países como turquía armenia
georgia israel eeuu e incluso canadá en
donde también hay establecidas grandes
comunidades ucranianas según la onu
europa debería prepararse para recibir
entre 4 y 5 millones de refugiados
procedentes de ucrania
sobre este tema preocupa a la unión
europea ya lo hemos visto en los últimos
días las declaraciones que han hecho
desde bruselas pero los reitero
precisamente yo soy por el el alto
representante de la unión europea para
los asuntos exteriores y la política de
seguridad estas fueron sus palabras
escuchemos
louis publishing debemos tener una
visión más política de nuestra ayuda
para asegurar que la comunidad
internacional primero que todo contiene
las acciones rusas establezca una
coalición para ayudar a los refugiados
ucranianos y apoye a los ucranianos
tanto a los que todavía están en el
campo de batalla como a los que
escaparon y corrieron para salvar sus
vidas a quienes debemos dar la
bienvenida como ya lo hicimos agua en
esta no es un ejemplo justo porque no
cogimos a 5 millones de afganos en
europa en este caso debemos estar
preparados para albergar alrededor de 5
millones de personas para usar entonces
el millón de personas en una segunda
mesa de diálogo entre las partes
involucradas en este conflicto fue
aprobada la creación de corredores
humanitarios unos corredores que
permitirían sacar personas hacia
territorio ruso que es como le decía el
país invasor una propuesta que fue
rechazada por las autoridades ucranianas
así lo indicó irina bereziuk que es la
primera vice primera ministra de ese
país escuchemos cn print y esta es una
opción inaceptable para la apertura de
corredores humanitarios
nuestra gente no irá de iván con
speed kibo y cerca de kiev a bielorrusia
para luego volar a la federación rusa
francisco federación así las cosas esta
europa comenzando un nuevo capítulo de
una crisis humanitaria a gran escala
dada esta guerra en ucrania que tan
preparados están los países receptores
para estas actividades humanitarias
porque se le abrió las puertas a los
ucranianos mientras que en el
mediterráneo' en otras fronteras como en
belarús o en turquía se ponen tantas
restricciones a aquellas personas que
están buscando refugio en los países de
la unión europea la crisis de refugiados
en europa por la guerra en ucrania es
nuestro tema de debate en france 24 y
para analizar este tema está con
nosotros elena muñoz ella es responsable
del servicio jurídico de la comisión
española de ayuda a los refugiados sean
nos acompaña desde la ciudad de madrid y
también está con nosotros fernando
henríquez el ciudadano ecuatoriano pero
es residente en la ciudad de lviv en el
oeste de ucrania fernando está allí
dando apoyo a diferentes albergues y
también está ayudando apoyo a los miles
de ciudadanos ucranianos y personas
residentes en este país que quieren
abandonar el país a través de las
fronteras del oeste ucraniano también
está con nosotros y nos acompaña a esta
hora pero ustedes también los
televidentes pueden ser parte de esta
conversación con sus comentarios y sus
preguntas lo pueden hacer a través de
las redes sociales no se encuentran en
facebook también en instagram y en
twitter estamos como france24 bajo ese
santi logo que es mi cuenta personal les
recuerdo nuestra etiqueta es numeral el
debate efe 24 esperamos todos los
comentarios y preguntas relacionadas con
este tema me voy a saltar un poco los
protocolos no le voy a dar la palabra a
elena como lo indica el protocolo darle
primero la palabra a la mujer en este
caso voy a comenzar con fernando en el
oeste de ucrania preguntándole por su
actividad lo que está haciendo allí
ayudando a las personas que tratan de
abandonar el país o que simplemente
escapan de la violencia que se está
registrando en la región del donbass y
se van a este lado del país que está un
poco más tranquilo en términos de
combates y enfrentamientos militares
fernando gracias por acompañarnos y
cuéntenos
lo que está haciendo usted allí
particularmente y cómo está la situación
humanitaria está bajo control como lo ve
usted
buenas buenas cartas buenos seguros es
bueno yo en general estoy ayudando a
ecuatorianos colombianos a todo
sudamericano en general
la citación nadia mente los primeros
días está bastante bastante fuerte
muchísimas personas que estaban saliendo
al día de hoy y está la situación mucho
más tranquila ahora se están viendo
muchísimo los zulianos a europa en
general por lo que tú mencionaste que
defienden vía libre al momento ha salido
muchísimas personas pero yo ayudo en la
manera que puedo tenemos nos ayudó
muchísimo una universidad que la
universidad estatal de libia la
politécnica para poder tener los
albergues
también estamos pudiendo ayudar en la
forma de poder viajar a polonia las
fronteras un bus es en este caso con
taxis de nuestra manera que se pueda al
principio fue muy difícil porque todo
estaba muy complicado la situación de
conseguir todo eso
pero fernando le doy la palabra ahora a
elena para preguntarle si esta situación
está salida masiva de ucranianos en tan
solo 12 días ha tomado por sorpresa a
europa que tan preparado estaba la unión
europea para empezar a recibir a toda
esta cantidad de personas ya lo decíamos
se pueden estimar hasta unos 4 ó 5
millones de personas abandonando ese
país
pues la unión europea ha activado una
una directiva que estaba disponible pero
hasta ahora nunca se había activado de
protección temporal y
entendemos que con esta directiva así
que se puede dar respuesta a este éxodo
mayoritario de personas provenientes del
cráneo
elena polonia ha sido el país que más
personas ha recibido hasta este momento
que ayuda le está dando que soporte edad
bruselas al gobierno polaco que se ha
mostrado muy abierto desde el principio
de la crisis a recibir a los ucranianos
como ha sido ese engranaje entre
varsovia y bruselas
pues a la vez que hacía la activación de
esta directiva por la que se le va a dar
un permiso de residencia y trabajo a las
personas que han unido a uno y de
ucrania del día 24 de febrero
este permiso trabajo de relaciones de
trabajo supone también una libertad de
movimientos dentro de la unión europea
por lo que la propia europea considera
que las propias personas ucranianas o
residentes en ucrania se moverán de
forma natural por los países de la
región europea para buscar el lugar de
residencia más adecuado a sus
circunstancias personales por donde
tengan redes o redes familiares redes de
amigos por tanto consideran a día de hoy
que no va a ser necesario hacer este
traslado o estas reubicaciones
de personas refugiadas o personas en
necesidad de protección temporal de unos
países europeos a otros sino que se
moverán por sus propiedades por sus
propios medios fernando allí en el oeste
de ucrania entiendo que lo que usted
hace es un servicio voluntario que
reciben ustedes algún tipo de ayuda por
parte del gobierno ucraniano o de
organismos internacionales como hacen
ustedes para financiar este
operación que están desarrollando allí
de manera voluntaria que la verdad la
verdad no he tenido
ayuda financiera de nadie
honestamente todo lo hemos hecho
con los mismos
mismos
recursos dijeron las personas la verdad
no puede salir de aquí
honestamente lucania
ecuador ayudó nos ayudó una persona con
el costo en este caso de
el cónsul luis narváez en este caso de
biela es la persona que nos pudo ayudar
y hacer los contactos en general él
estuvo aquí y es la persona que nos pudo
de verdad ayudar en casi todo en estos
momentos pero de allí otros gobiernos
cuando puedes hilo pues la verdad no
económicamente tampoco todo lo hemos
hecho con ayuda como te dije de la
universidad es la que nos ha ayudado
muchísimo y lo demás con cada persona
que pagaba para poder salir ellos mismos
cuando es también fernando yo supongo
obviamente por las circunstancias en las
que estaban allí en en ucrania las
escenas no son muy alentadoras y las
personas dejan su país en condiciones
muy difíciles pero el sentimiento
general de estos ciudadanos ucranianos
que se van del país se van con el
sentimiento de irse por un corto periodo
de tiempo o se van dejando todo atrás
con la idea en mente de no volver a
ucrania en el mediano o largo plazo cuál
es el sentimiento general que percibe
usted de ellos
tienes que ver que el azúcar no son muy
nacionalistas
ellos llaman muchísimo su país
entonces yo creo que se acaba esto y
muchas personas lo más seguro es que
vayan a estar acá en general no sólo
crean los igual extranjeros en general
lo mismo por tener a los peruanos
colombianos
porque es un país muy bonito
y aquí
el then hablábamos de ese permiso que se
les está facilitando a las
personas que están abandonando ucrania
que llegan al territorio polaco pero
precisamente polonia es un país del cual
también muchos polacos se han ido para
buscar mejores oportunidades en otros
países de la unión europea hay un nexo
constante de polacos hacia alemania
hacia suiza en islandia por ejemplo son
la comunidad extranjera más grande y de
trabajadores
extranjeros más grande que tantas
oportunidades pueden tener ellos en
polonia para rehacer su vida si deciden
definitivamente quedarse fuera de
ucrania
como te he dicho el incluso antes de
hacer la solicitud del permiso de
residencia y trabajo
tienen libertad de movimientos durante
90 días dentro del espacio schengen es
decir no es necesario que se queden en
polonia una vez que hayan entrado en
territorio europeo pueden durante esos
90 días trasladarse a otros países de la
unión europea y solicitar este permiso
de residencia y trabajo esta protección
temporal en cualquiera de los países de
la unión europea porque todos estamos
obligados por la directiva de que no va
a recaer sólo en polonia sino que según
la comisión de manera natural seguirán
redistribuyendo por todos los países de
la unión europea si se ve que esa
redistribución es natural no se produce
la propia unión europea contempla la
posibilidad de hacer un reparto más
equitativo pero en principio confían que
la propia naturaleza de las redes
familiares
redes de amistades que tienen la
población ucraniana sea favorable a
redistribuir a las personas por otros
países de la unión europea el dni porque
este tipo de escenario este tipo de
facilidades no se le ha dado a otro tipo
de refugiados
por ejemplo procedentes de siria en su
momento en el momento álgido del
conflicto en siria o con los refugiados
que llegan a través de aguas del
mediterráneo
cuando tuvo lugar la guerra y el
conflicto en irak y en afganistán porque
se toma esta decisión y esta directiva
en este escenario y en otros no
pues es una pregunta que nosotros
también nos hacemos en todos esos
escenarios que has comentado en
2015 cuando fue la llegada de personas
mayoritariamente de siria por la vía
turquía grecia cuando han llegado por la
vía central del mediterráneo
con esas imágenes dantescas que vimos en
de personas falleciendo en la vía de
libia a italia o lo que hemos vivido
también en españa con las personas que
intentan cruzar a canarias y los
peligros que viven desde sea shepherd
hemos solicitado que apliquen esta
directiva de protección internación de
protección temporal perdona que como os
he dicho ésta está publicada o esta
puesta en vigor y podía ser activada en
cualquier momento desde 2001 que fue
cuando se aprobó
la activación de esta directiva es
verdad que necesitan mayorías
cualificadas del consejo de la unión
europea es decir donde están
representados los
27 estados miembros y la lógica
intergubernamental de los 27 estados
miembros pues es muy diferente que ante
un éxodo de ucrania que ante un nexo del
mejor decir yo de otros países
fernando en días anteriores veíamos
varias denuncias a través de redes
sociales incluso varios artículos de
prensa a nivel internacional hablaba de
una diferenciación entre el tipo de
persona que iba a salir de territorio
ucraniano los ciudadanos nacionales
tenían más facilidades y hubo denuncias
de algunos vetos para los ciudadanos que
eran de origen africano o de origen del
medio oriente
usted ha podido ser testigo de algo así
que haya una diferenciación o que se
retrase el proceso de salida de
ciudadanos latinoamericanos africanos y
se le dé prioridad a los ucranianos
es la verdad
yo no lo viví pero sí sí me contaron
muchísimo esa situación está bastante
fuerte pero tienes que ver que al final
pues
es un país yo sigo en la actualidad su
gente en los principios pero sí sí se
dio muchísima un poco más de
discriminación en general
pero era porque todos querían la idea y
la verdad estaba muy fuerte la situación
pero más fue forest pero sí sería toda
esta situación que espero pero esta
decisión darle prioridad a la salida de
los ucranianos se debía a la alta
afluencia de personas allí en los puntos
fronterizos para salir y simplemente por
organización logística y rapidez se
facilitaba la salida de los ucranianos
puede ser por algo ya
premeditado algún tipo de razón
específica que cree usted desde el
análisis que usted puede hacer
mirar honestamente
había muchísimas personas que estaba
saliendo eran miles miles de personas
y la prioridad siempre eran mujeres
niños y obviamente a su gente el igual a
ver primero pero no creo que haya sido
para decir mira porque tú eres aplicando
porque puedes darme tu eres
latinoamericano bueno iré al último y al
final también tienes que ver que son
tropas eran militares y tienen alguien
más arriba y más arriba que le está
mandando
entonces la verdad esa es la situación
pero sí o sea sí estuvo muy feo y
había mucha discriminación
fernando allí hay puestos fronterizos
hay algunos que son muy concurridos que
tienen digamos una capacidad de
instalaciones para albergar a mayor
cantidad de personas que están haciendo
todo este proceso para el control de
pasaportes para entrar a territorio de
la unión europea pero hay unos puntos
fronterizos que son muy pequeños donde
ha estado completamente desbordada la
capacidad usted ha visto allí en dónde
está usted si ha llegado más
funcionarios para agilizar los procesos
y personal militar como usted lo
mencionaba para agilizar esta salida de
las personas o simplemente se ha
mantenido la logística normal y los
sitios están desbordados
en estos momentos
pues no ya va a estar bastante mucho más
fácil la verdad poder
en un principio era muy complicado por
los miles miles de personas que estaban
la verdad no he visto lo visto si es que
habrá más personas o menos personas
me refiero a militares lo más seguro es
que debe estar lo mismo porque todos los
que estamos entrando en otras partes del
país
con toda la situación de negocio de
carne pero debe ser similar honestamente
no creo que haga un cambio muy grande
pero ahora está mucho más fácil salir
del país honestamente elena vuelvo con
ustedes allí en la ciudad de madrid para
preguntarle muchos medios también se
habla de una crisis humanitaria una
crisis de refugiados los números ya nos
dan para pensar que estamos ante una
crisis o es simplemente
una alta afluencia de personas que están
abandonando este país por el conflicto
de acuerdo a la teoría o cómo lo manejan
ustedes
cuando se puede hablar de una crisis de
refugiados
a nivel teórico no te puedo no te puedo
decir porque no soy una teórica sino más
bien una abogada práctica de la materia
yo creo que a día de hoy en la unión
europea está preparada y se ha dotado
con esta aplicación de la directiva para
asumir y para absorber este flujo de
refugiados y por tanto no creo que
podamos hablar todavía de una crisis es
verdad que como os habéis dicho al
principio de la de la introducción de
este debate
los números están creciendo es el
crecimiento mayor desde la segunda
guerra mundial en cuanto a flujos de
movimiento pero creo que a día de hoy
los sistemas europeos de protección
temporal y de protección internacional
para aquellas personas que necesiten
solicitar asilo están preparados
hablábamos hace unos minutos de la ayuda
de la unión europea pero aquí hay
también países que no tienen nada que
ver con bruselas el caso de moldavia por
ejemplo es un país que no pertenece a la
unión europea es un país muy pequeño que
incluso tiene algunas características
parecidas a ucrania tiene también una
región separatista prorrusa y por allí
también están atravesando muchos
ucranianos hay algún tipo de ayuda
también a moldavia que está recibiendo
más de 100 dã o ha recibido más de
100.000 refugiados procedentes de
ucrania y moldavia simplemente tiene que
acudir a los organismos internacionales
a gran escala como manejan allí la
situación
bueno es la umh europea ha activado
también
el mecanismo de protección civil para
apoyar a los países fronterizos
desconozco ahora con detalle cuál es la
ayuda que recibe directamente moldavia
pero sí que se está intentando realizar
esta está ayuda a los países fronterizos
con ucrania si en la jornada de hoy
precisamente el gobierno moldavo en
chisinau pidió ayuda a estados unidos
para poder hacer frente a esta crisis
humanitaria es un país que
económicamente tiene muchas dificultades
y está teniendo que hacer frente a esta
situación humanitaria allí en su
frontera común con ucrania fernando me
remito ahora a que hablemos
no tanto analizar la situación de lo que
se está viviendo allí sino de las
actividades que ustedes hacen como es el
día a día de ustedes cómo se organizan
cómo articulan ustedes la actividad
cuántas personas son qué actividades con
qué actividades comienzan el día para
ayudar a estas personas que necesitan
abandonar el país cómo es su día a día
bueno en un principio
era ir a verles al albergue donde
teníamos ahí vivimos más o menos las 40
personas y ahí puedes dirigirnos a los
buses obviamente buscaron un bus que nos
pueda ayudar en general para poder
llevar a todos los picos legales
pero cuando tienen esta ciudad no ha
pasado nada por suerte entonces eso toda
la guerra no ha habido ningún
inconveniente en bombas ni nada por el
estilo entonces eso es obviamente lo
bastante bueno hasta el momento pero por
lo general
podría ayudarle en la mañana tratar de
despachar siempre todo en la mañana para
que no sea muy complicado en la tarde y
que ellos pueden estar a polonia en
general u otras partes de
la colonia fernando cuando usted dice
despachar se refiere a ayudar a estas
personas en qué forma ayudarlos a hacer
el trámite agilizar solo ante las
autoridades
a qué sitios deben acudir para hacer las
filas donde donde hacen el proceso de
chequeo de pasaportes de los más
detalles
mira en este caso nos eso de adora que
fronteras nos ayudando un poco más jode
los taxistas y los mismos conductores y
no dicen miran el día de hoy está buena
irse a esta frontera vale a buscar a va
a irse a otra frontera esta frontera
desde ellos son las personas que nos
indican a nosotros pues nadie corrupción
para el día de hoy y después obviamente
los papeles simplemente el pasaporte
siendo el pasaporte virtual que
igualmente
no es tan complicado pero simplemente
hay que tener organización nada más y
usted le sirve de guía para ubicarse en
esta zona del país donde de pronto es un
territorio desconocido para muchos
ucranianos que vienen desde otras
regiones elena lo mencionaba en la
introducción del programa estos
corredores humanitarios que fueron
pactados entre rusia y ucrania en su
segunda mesa de conversaciones y que fue
rechazada tajantemente por el gobierno
de ucrania porque la oferta que se hacía
era las personas salieran hacia rusia a
través de estos corredores este tipo de
propuestas a estos corredores que tan
eficientes son para este tipo de
actividades muchas personas especulan
que cuando se abren estos corredores es
porque esto da pie a una escalada
militar y esto podríamos estar a pocas
horas de una gran incursión del ejército
ruso en diferentes ciudades del país que
se sabe sobre esto como lo ven ustedes
que se analiza a través de estos de
estas propuestas de los corredores
y no soy experta en estrategia militar
pero sí que se puede llegar a entender
que tras
evacuar una ciudad de población civil
puede llegar un ataque militar más más
profundo o de mayor alcance precisamente
por haber evacuado previamente a los
civiles de la misma la realidad es que a
día de hoy las tres intentos que ha
habido de crear corredores humanitarios
han fracasado no se han cumplido y de
hecho tenemos imágenes muy dolorosas de
familias
fallecidas bombardeadas con las maletas
cuando justamente estaban intentando
salir de las ciudades asediadas así que
a día de hoy no ha sido efectivo estos
corredores y
y probablemente si la alternativa es ir
rusia o bielorrusia no van a ser
efectivos tampoco el dni dentro de lo
que se puede hacer lo que marca la
ley en este marco de este tipo de
conflictos que se puede hacer para
garantizar entonces la seguridad de los
ciudadanos que están en el fuego cruzado
y permitirles salir garantizarles ayuda
humanitaria a llevárselas hasta sus
lugares
y hacer alguna tregua no sé qué es lo
que se ve en la parte legal para este
tipo de escenarios bueno
las convenciones de ginebra que son las
que establecen las leyes de la guerra
lo dejan claro un civil nunca puede ser
un objetivo militar por tanto no es
ilegal bombardear una vía de evacuación
de los civiles es en contrario al
derecho internacional por tanto lo
primero va a ser garantizar siempre la
vía de los civiles la vida de los
civiles perdonas y las infraestructuras
básicas para la vida de los civiles como
pueden ser centrales eléctricas
centrales hidroeléctricas suministros de
agua
extremos que por la información que nos
llega con todas las cautelas porque en
un conflicto armado por la información
no siempre es la más precisa quizá
parece ser que no se está respetando en
este en este conflicto
fernando me llama la atención cuando
conversó con usted bueno ya lo
mencionaba es ecuatoriano está lleno en
el oeste de ucrania
me llama la atención y tal vez me da un
poco de curiosidad saber por qué está
usted en ucrania porque está allí y
cuando se va a ir de ucrania
y yo estoy aquí bueno porque bueno ya
viene hace nueve años la verdad
y luego viene por estudiar terminé mi
carrera y me quedé trabajando en este
país
y cuando me voy a ir no sé la verdad no
estoy muy seguro cuándo voy a ir
cuando se acabe esto si es que se pueden
obviamente más más fuerte la citación y
obviamente pienso a irme otro otro país
pero la verdad es que
mi familia si es
de 9 años en ucrania 9 años siendo parte
de la cotidianidad de este país llevando
una vida completamente normal ustedes en
algún momento pensaron que el país iba a
ser invadido por rusia de acuerdo a la
información que recibían como ciudadanos
del común los ucranianos fueron tomados
por sorpresa
la verdad es que no fue algo de la nada
estaba durmiendo y picado en las bombas
esto fue sin más y espero que empezara
esto por estas
máquinas
fernando y para terminar este bloque de
preguntas
algo que hemos visto también desde este
lado del atlántico es que se ha llamado
a la unidad de los ucranianos ha habido
un sentimiento de patriotismo muy fuerte
para defender el país que comentan los
ucranianos sobre este conflicto como ven
a rusia un país al que han pertenecido
en el pasado y ahí tienen más de 300
años de historia en común que comentan
los ucranianos sobre esto que están
viviendo
mira la verdad es que ellos
hace muchísimo tiempo que no se prende
de rusia en absoluto
la verdad es que hace mucho tiempo que
quieren pertenecer a europa honestamente
entonces ellos se creen un poco más
europeos la verdad pero
la historia siempre va a ser historia
honestamente y si son muy patriotas esos
que no nos son muy patriotas aman
muchísimo su país
como yo igual como amo mi país y cómo
vamos de país también
sí pero ellos
lo comentábamos y lo vimos en los
últimos días esta aproximación que ha
hecho rápidamente el gobierno ucraniano
para comenzar su trámite para
incorporarse a la unión europea que
tanto tiene esto de estratégico por la
circunstancia en la que están para poder
acceder a ayudas procedentes de bruselas
y acelerar un poco
ayuda de otros países a través del
bloque europeo
es factible que ucrania pueda acceder a
más ayudas y acceder a esas leyes
europeas
simplemente por esta esta primera firma
de un
país candidato esto que en qué se
traduce para ucrania
bueno la candidatura una candidatura a
ser miembro de la unión europea es
bastante larga hay países que llevan 10
años 14 años en ese camino porque a
partir de que se inicia ese
procedimiento se establecen lo que se
llaman los capítulos
de cumplimiento de reformas que se
necesitan hacer en el país para poder
cumplir los requisitos mínimos de
entrada de respeto de los derechos
humanos respeto del estado de derecho
lucha contra la corrupción
[Música]
y por otros países candidatos que llevan
un camino bastante
bastante más andado creo que ucrania
todavía le quedará le quedará algún
tiempo para poder un clic todo este
camino de adhesión a la unión europea sí
que es verdad que conforme se van
cumpliendo algunos de estos capítulos se
pueden ir recibiendo ayudas para
ejecutar esas reformas requeridas y en
ahí ahí sí que puede recibir algún tipo
de ayuda pero no sé no o no creo
sinceramente que en el contexto de
conflicto armado que está viviendo
ucrania tenga capacidad para ejecutar
reformas en el estado de derecho o en
lucha contra la corrupción por tanto
quizás no es el momento de ejecutar esas
reformas y sí que estaríamos hablando de
un escenario más a medio largo plazo
claro me queda un minuto para finalizar
el programa fernando que cree usted que
va a suceder como ve usted la situación
de cara al futuro el conflicto sigue y
la mesa de diálogo todavía no arroja
algún resultado prometedor que cree
usted que va a suceder
bueno yo creo que esto es una
de
es una guerra de esperar la verdad de
desgaste entonces con todas las
sanciones que está teniendo a rusia
esperemos que
bueno sacarle rápido esto
les quiero agradecer a elena ya fernando
por haber estado con nosotros en el
programa ustedes pueden seguir dejando
sus comentarios a través de las redes
sociales gracias por su sintonía
[Música]